vamos a darnos un poquito de práctica
con logaritmos así que solo como un
pequeño repaso vamos a evaluar el
logaritmo base 2 de 8
qué es esto como como lo calculamos
bueno si nos preguntan calcular esto en
realidad es la potencia o el exponente a
la cual tengo que elevar nuestra base
tengo que elevar 2 a la que para llegar
a 8 así que 2 a la 1 es 2 2 a las 12 42
al a3 y es ocho así que esto de aquí es
3 muy bien ya hicimos bastantes ejemplos
de esto en el último vídeo vamos a hacer
algo un poquito más interesante que es
que es y lo voy a colorear de esta forma
cuál es la el logaritmo base 8 de dos
dedos vamos a poner 2 ahora esto es
interesante te va a dar unos cuantos
segundos para que lo pienses bueno nos
preguntan cómo evaluar el exponente al
al cual tengo que elevar 8 para obtener
dos así que pensemos de esto de otra
forma así que podemos decir que 8 a la
alguna potencia x digamos ese es el
exponente de al cual tengo que elevar 8
es esencialmente el logaritmo y el 8 a
la x debe ser igual a 2 debe ser igual a
bueno si dos a la que es 8 a la 3 2 a la
entonces x es igual a la un tercio
porque 8 a la un tercio es igual a 2
elevar a la un tercio es lo mismo que
sacar raíz cúbica así que esto es un
tercio el logaritmo base 8 de 2 va a ser
un tercio muy bien fascinante
ahora vamos a mezclar un poquito más
digamos que tenemos el logaritmo base 2
y en vez de 8 vamos a poner 1 sobre 81
octavo justo aquí así que te voy a dar
otros segunditos para que lo pienses
bueno nos preguntan cómo evaluar el
exponente al cual tengo que elevar 2
para que nos dé un octavo así que si
ponemos que esto es igual a equis
esencialmente nos dicen 2 a la equis
debe ser igual debe ser igual a un
octavo debe ser igual a un octavo
pero sabemos que 2 al cubo o 2 a la 3 es
igual a 8 2 a la 3 es igual a 8 si
queremos obtener el recíproco o el
inverso multiplicativo de 8 hay que
elevar a la menos 3 y esto va a ser
igual a 1 sobre todos a la 3 que es
igual a 1 sobre 8 así que si nos
preguntan a qué exponente debemos elevar
2 para que nos dé un octavo debe ser a
la menos tres y eso es porque elevará la
menos x igual a menos 3 elevar a la
menos es como ponerlo en el denominador
verdad
ahora vamos realmente a mezclar todo
esto cuál sería por ejemplo el logaritmo
base base 8 fase 8 de un medio
ok que hay que esto a que es igual de
que no es limpiar esto para que tengamos
cierto espacio para trabajar
así que como siempre nos preguntan a qué
potencia debo elevar 8 para obtener un
medio así que pensemos un poquito de
esto sabemos que 8 a la un tercio es
igual a 2 ok si queremos el recíproco de
2 tenemos que elevar al 8 a la menos un
tercio así que vamos a escribir esto
esto es 8 a la menos un tercio va a ser
igual a 1 sobre 8 a la un tercio verdad
eso es la definición de que elevamos a
un número a un número negativo y esto es
igual a un medio así que el logaritmo
base 8 de un medio es igual es igual a
bueno ya obtuvimos que 8 a la menos un
tercio nos da eso entonces esto es menos
un tercio
espero lados se hayan divertido tanto
como lo hice yo